dimmi tutto cos'è che vuoi noi caripe
finita o ragazzi mi raccomando le
mascherine quando venite al bancone che
se vengono a farmi un controllo cuamm i
tumori lido è lasciando raffa b per la
signora un caffè shakerato macchiato
poco piace tanto caffè non zuccherato in
tazza grande stellina io ti conosco da
quando sei nata tu non li ai sedicenni
non te lo posso dare molto noto papà
vieni qua in italia le gambine capito un
tavolo per francia per oggi barre di
controllo ma non credo proprio è il
primo libro glielo dico al 27 settembre
le 12 e poeta che faccio lo prenoto
signora sanno arrivare romagnola ad
agosto cosa si aspetta 2 capresi
un'insalata mista ai graffi naturally 7
ma lei non aveva preso anche un caffè è
signora provano devi dire ehi non è che
è facciamo due caffè si allora 289 euro
80 un tè la pesca anno la festa non c'è
al limone al limone finito cosa che ti
serve alla pasta e wifi si è lavoro solo
tre mesi guardando più dita in un anno
tutto piccolo tutta peccato con i tre
numero ciao